yeah no one welcome home to this video
blitz chess number 44 80 okay
yeah let's see tap test is my opponent
to 280 rated let's see 4 if I have not
decided yet what's going to happen if he
goes night if 3 maybe I go for the
petrov when i'm currently looking at a
bit but he's not playing him what's
going on here what is going on here took
a moment to move
that's a bit weird I mean not playing is
kind of it sometimes happen so that
people start a game then they simply
never make a move but playing the first
one and then not playing against e5 is a
bit odd yep
maybe he just wants to give me a little
bit of a head start in the way that I'm
old and slow possible hmm okay maybe
just has a doorbell ringing or something
yeah so we have the petrov and play this
knight c6 line that still seems to
surprise people I'm quite I'm quite
amazed that this is still the case this
finally looking admittedly funny looking
movers already my room for ages like
close to 20 years and so people are
totally taken aback by by um anyway so
what is this queenie - I've never seen
dad hmm okay if I Kobe should be seven
he can take on e4 maybe and win a pawn I
mean that this could be compensation
even this however looks quite normal
like unpinning and threatening both
pieces again canceling looks very very
normal
yeah maybe I'm not sure of that that
Queen e7 move was really the best
solution I would like to take the bishop
but after Queen takes my development is
really a bit lagging and he threatening
rupee one I can take on f3 but after
Queen takes that porn is hanging I mean
it's still probably going to be fine I'm
winning a tempo a bit I think he has to
cover d4 and now yeah the question is is
long castling Nair long castling looks a
bit weird in the situation he's ready to
play before a four and so on so probably
I will rather prepare to Castle short
and looks rather equal ish this position
very symmetrical okay rupee one yeah
cancelling short should be fine no I got
an important phone call hmm okay right
after the game
yam okay this is again as I said rather
equal in fact if anybody can claim a
little something it's probably white
reasoning that he's got somewhat better
bishop on d3 it's not something that
amounts to much but it's the only little
difference let's say between two sides
here I cannot conveniently take
unfortunately as then the pawn will
capture and it looks a little bit
uncomfortable and after age six played I
cannot so easily play f6 yeah there are
little things here that I'm a bit
worrisome okay what I try is to play
okay and that's a very direct way of
playing but not a bad one of course hmm
yeah just going for loop g3 I guess
Bishop c8 there's Knight takes f7 which
is really annoying I wanted to move the
bishop
yeah not it's not not nice really isn't
what I'm doing here with all those
backward moves trying to play of six I
have six Queen g6 does that threaten
anything I don't think it does actually
I still feel like this is shaky I'm just
a static him but this is not probably
going to kill me but that's him yeah it
is very inconvenient very inconvenient
the the Queen coming to age seven and
then you've got tonight to g6 always in
the in the mix I don't really know what
to do no I didn't see that one coming
oh what a bad game
pretty terrible player what I did in
this game was really bad Bishop f7 was
winning the whole time I know it's a
draw
why is that I mean okay it's a
repetition but you can just play
whatever hmm okay
I always extremely lucky yeah mainly it
started out being really equal like here
I mean okay the engine thinks why this
better but I don't don't believe it I
mean okay of course white is a bit
better this is not the yeah but I don't
think it's anything substantial like +1
or something but it initially displayed
him aged 6 9 f3 I think I probably have
to start to improve around here maybe
rookie 7 is still liked by the engine
actually and maybe I have to take it but
I didn't probably have to I mean taking
with the piece I'm not worried about I
was worried about the poor CAPTCHA
actually but this is the same
I really yeah what I did not really see
is that when I go Queen to b6 as it is
not all that easy for him to get this
into play I mean I was very dead f4 f5
will happen and this is a plan but it's
not easy to play I mean obviously can
right now it's against the rules but he
also has to worry about the pawn and I
have this okay then I should definitely
take on e5 because I mean the rook
capture or queen capture let's say this
is not the problem really I can do this
goes back somewhere up the ship f7 this
is just going to be totally equal yeah
nothing happens and now it got really a
bit unpleasant again I did not take you
to the porn capture but I have to take
and from here it gets awkward and the
engine already gives other moves but
yeah the Queen g6 was already working I
was thinking I can take but obviously
this is also not true
I forgot what his point hey again yeah
it was pretty awful and here I should
probably not lose directly but we should
be sixes of course a lot better to play
Bishop
f7 oh I could have taken d5 oops yeah
[Music]
95 yeah I really I played a really awful
game I mean like anything when you
Bishop f5 was a simple solution which is
something I didn't play and it's got
that we got repetition all of a sudden
he definitely I don't think he really
wanted it I think it he stumbled into
the repetition yeah that was pretty
awful pretty awful the main thing that I
did not sense correctly was that that
here context isn't actually a problem
now what I also want to briefly check is
after Queenie - yeah Queenie 7 is
actually liked by the engine and now I'd
want to go Bishop to g4 yeah that I
didn't really think about all that much
and this is also things as better yeah I
essentially the same ideas in the game
and then Queen d7 here you can maybe
cancer long and with there is a light
squared Bishop being out of the game
makes the whole thing a little bit safer
yeah okay that is also an improvement
also this is an improvement ma'am okay I
hope next games going to be better
thanks for watching